martin perez four and two of the 309 era
correa has been really good his last 10
games hitting 371.
wow correa 3-1 pitch it's a high
fly ball towards left is this ball fair
that ball
is gone home run carlos correa he's not
sure
down that foul pole where carlton fisk
had to use some body english to keep it
fair correa
was kind of guessing like us and it was
called fair
by the third base umpire brian gorman
and right now it's going to be a home
run correa hits home run number 11
on the season matching kyle tucker for
the most on the team and giving the
astros a one-nothing lead
from valdez is going to be your houston
astros starting pitcher this will be his
third start of the season
so two out of nobody on for shortstop
xander bogarts
swinging a miss got him with the
breaking ball that's robert valdez with
a one two three inning to start this one
a couple of groundouts in a strikeout
michael brantley his first at bat and
michael shoots one the other way
there's hit number one welcome back off
the injured list michael brantley
he will test out that hamstring but
doesn't have to run hard
as he trots into second base with a lead
off double here in the second
tucker's been on a good roll recently
and over the course of the last few
weeks
he faces part team perez here
first pitch swinging sends one to center
field pretty well hit hernandez back he
will watch it bounce off the wall
he barehands it and that will keep
brantley on third base but tucker ends
up with a double
back-to-back doubles but a nice play by
[ __ ] hernandez to get the ball back in
quickly
so brantley at third tucker at second
and here's maldonado
there's a ball ripped down the line in
left field that'll score
two tucker right behind brantley martin
maldonado with a two rbi base hit
and the astros lead this game three to
nothing
it's maldonado at second straw at first
two runs home in the inning
now it's correa he homer down the left
field line his first time up
and he rips one down the left field line
that is a fair ball
and that is in play in the corner into
score maldonado miles straw will be held
up at third carlos correa
a home run and an rbi double already
tonight and the astros have jumped out
in front four to nothing
carlos correa cutting down on that leg
kick that he talked about
the foot is down on time and the hands
are like lightning right now through the
zone
jordan alvarez with the bases loaded
inside almost hit him it did get him oh
wow bases loaded hit
batter makes it a five nothing game
everybody advances 90 feet and perez
continues to really struggle with his
command
now you've got euler with the bases
loaded astros on a team that usually is
are content they could keep going for
more
there's a ball base hitting the left
field julie does it again
rbi single with the bases loaded drives
in run number six
and the astros move 90 feet up at every
base bottom of the second jd martinez
another swinging strike on the breaking
ball back to back k's getting bogarts to
end the first and jd martinez
to start the second two out no one on
for marwan gonzalez
a little chopper towards third bregman
will have to hustle his throw
in time to get his former teammate
marwan gonzalez to end the inning
fromber has retired the first six
and the astros lead early six nothing
here's kristen arroyo their leadoff man
runner on first
swinging a miss he got all the
strikeouts on curveballs that inning
back to back to back
from rolling along through three innings
with five
strikeouts batting first in the fourth
inning is correa in five base hits
correa three for three has a home run a
double and now a single
as he starts out the fourth inning with
a base hit only one thing left to do
the rest of the night for carlos correa
now has a
single double and a home run continuing
to swing a hot bat
matt andres 31 years old 6-2 217 pounds
from
redlands california he bounces it up
there knocked down by flowecky correa
not going anywhere
there's a change up right there that
bounces up and gets him right in the
mask or right almost under the mask
checking his jaw right now
and now here comes alex cora yeah right
at the bottom of the mask and
apparently john his jaw or something
because that's the area that he's been
complaining about right now you could
barely hear it down one of our
microphones but alex corey is saying if
you don't feel
right i'm sure we could complete the
rest of that sentence you're coming out
of the game
yeah it's going to take him right out so
the night is over for kevin plawecki
and so christian vasquez will enter the
fray
well jordan alvarez will bat that ball
smoke to center field all the way back
[ __ ] hernandez and he will
let it go deep home run by air your dodd
the straight away center field jordan
with his first home run
in his last 17 games
and gives the astros a seven nothing
lead
he's on a renfro he is o for one with a
ground out to short
devers at third martinez at first
another one softly roll to bregman
they'll fire on to first base get the
out out number two is debras is in to
score the rbi for 100 rent pro
and the red sox on the scoreboard to
make it 7-1
so the lead man on for houston here's
michael brantley
as one hit ground ball here and taken by
arroyo guns in the second
i'm the first for the double play
so four to five to three
outstanding play by arroyo just
continues to make good defensive stops
kyle tucker maybe some onion
shallow right field arroyo leaving his
feet and
fired a dart on to first base to get the
out
proper went seven innings against the
red sox last outing allowed five hits in
a run
this one is tough play and bregman will
try and bare hand it
and a great play by alex bregman to
retire [ __ ] hernandez
bregman with a fine defensive play for
the second half of the inning
about to make his 90th pitch of the
night he has
not been in too many high stretch stress
situations
looks like they want to go to the
curveball 2-2 and a swinging strike
from valdez a one-two-three inning has
eight strikeouts through
seven craigman at second guriel who
took a walk is on it first and the two
nothing
to kyle tucker
it's a high fly ball well struck in the
right center to the triangle hernandez
back there back there
fencing way out there in the triangle to
haul it in
two men stranded and they'll go to the
lefty here blake taylor
as dalbeck stands in he is over his last
10 and 3 for 37 but there's a ball
rocking it up the middle but
right there is jose altuve and that will
do it ball game
over blake taylor finishes things out in
the ninth inning
the astros win the first game against
the red sox 7-1